on H what you got going on so what's the
topic Jesus Is God change my mind Jesus
Is God Christianity is true whatever
whatever problems you got with
Christianity man you can bring them
you're a
Muslim uh yeah okay yeah whatever
whatever issues you have with
Christianity you can bring them if you
just want to tell me why Islam is true
you can talk about that and we can you
know wherever you want to go with it so
can you give me
the reference where you had that said
that Jesus is God
that Jesus
claimed he claimed yeah yeah where he
claimed it where is that he claimed yeah
re Revelation chap 22 verse 13 he
claimed it in the gospel yeah yeah re
ration how many years it doesn't it
doesn't matter it's him
speaking he was already
gone him leaving the Earth doesn't mean
he doesn't exist
anymore the differ why do do you believe
when you do you believe when you die or
like you or when you go to heaven for
example when you go to heaven you're
going to not exist or you just move to
the next life
right
um let's let's let's stick right here
let's go let's go back to the top he I
want to hear what he say his when one
his disciples he never claimed
himself yeah this is John never claimed
his disciples he always said the son of
man no no well the son of man is God
that's another thing everybody the devil
the devil the Devils of the evil spirits
call on the Son of
God or God himself and other people did
he never made that claim himself I
verified myself he never made a claim
that what he never made a claim himself
he never called himself God he never
called himself God only thing no he did
only thing close to saying that when he
said he quoted Psalms he quoted psms I
believe I don't want Li he quoted a
Psalm where it said ye are Gods he
quoted that okay well let's talk about
this who's the first and the last the
Alpha and the Omega the beginning and
the
end okay who that who
that the Creator that's right I agree
the one that has no beginning the one
who has no end boom Jesus says I am the
Alpha and the Omega the beginning and
the end the first and the last it's
Revelation 2213 uh you keep going to
Revelation this Revelation Revelation
was put in the Bible years after no it
was in the it was in the scriptures and
and it's been in the scriptures by by
the
church had Vis he was on the island of
Patmos what's wrong with that okay where
where is that at but wait what's wrong
with that where is that at where is it
at why why does that matter he spoke
with Jesus say I'm saying it's
influenced by who the same people was in
that region years John had a vision and
Jesus visited him in a vision and told
him who he was what's the
problem he had a vision we talking about
a man who claimed he had the vision a
man who claimed he had the vision all
right he's the only person who made this
claim nobody else is the only person
made this I was waiting on you
to no wor no worries I was I was
actually waiting on you to say that
you're a Muslim right okay I know where
you going to go I know where you going
to go come on come on okay come on so
who was a witness to Muhammad's
experience in the
cave there are PL of
[Music]
different times when he received
Revelation he I'm I'm asking
specifically about his cave experience
hold on hold on hold on nobody was there
and if you know the story correctly what
happened once he left the cave he
thought he was tripping he thought he
lost his mind he wasn't sure that he
seen what he seen he didn't he wasn't
sure no he was he was sure about what he
CU he if you if you know the history he
thought he was demon
possessed who who did Muhammad he he
thought that he was being attacked by a
demon I mean he did too because he had
the vision I mean anybody who had the
vision who see pretty
you John didn't I mean even even even
Mary didn't know when the Angels Vision
mared she was she was scared too well
well but immediately but hold on
immediately you could be startled when
you see an angel but immediately the
angel announces who he is and what he's
there for and brings peace he literally
says peace don't be afraid and so every
person that an angel comes to including
Mary they are they have peace they don't
go they don't walk away from the
experience thinking that they were
demon-possessed
none of them
ever it's more tal in the sense and I
would say I I say this from a human
experience because Muhammad Jesus they
all human we we leave like that we all
humans so from a human experience
knowing that you just had this
Revelation or whatever you want to call
it this visit from this Divine Source or
whatever along with the fact that you
know you have a duty in front of you a
vast mission in front of you I'm pretty
sure any man will feel intimidated feel
crazy not sure of himself but not demon
possessed his wife was right there to
comfort him and let him know that you
are meant for this this is you are not
losing your mind he had had confirmation
many times no so so again I'm I'm
shaking my head because you're you're
taking Muhammad's experience and you're
you're coloring it don't color it let's
take it for what it was there wasn't a
single Prophet a single person who had
an experience with an angel coming to
them and giving them a
revelation and they left that experience
feeling as if they were demon-possessed
wanting to un alive
themselves that never
happened so look this is why this is
important because when you look at how
the prophets received Revelation whether
it's from God himself or if it was from
an angel if there's a
consistency you there's a peace that
they have there's a comfort that they
have and there's never a fear that they
have experienced a demon
ever ever so what does that tell you
when it comes to Muhammad what does it
tell you it tells you that Muhammad
experienced a demon not God or an
Angel that's your opinion though there
not we basically going off Theory
and and the I'm going I'm going off of
so this what I'm going off of I'm going
off of the consistency and the
continuity of the previous prophets
their experiences right what how how
they experienced the Angels how they
experienced God putting that in a
collective we have a large sample size
put that all okay they it's all like
this I look at Muhammad's experience
nothing like that nothing like the large
body of of examples that we have that's
number one number two I look at what
comes after what did Muhammad teach was
it in line with the prophets or was it
against what the prophets collectively
taught and the answer is what Muhammad
taught was was against the collective
message of the prophets how
so for example the prophets taught that
God was the father was the heavenly
father no hold on first of all let's go
back to where this came from we talking
about prophets who was of the Jewish
tribe the Jewish This Is How They Tau
this is their terminology this is their
terminology and the word father the word
father that they use in the language
that they spoke did not mean father have
we seen yes it does it father the word
the word was simple it was OB or ABA it
was simple okay it literally means
father you can be a father in many
senses you can be an adopted father you
can be a literal father you can you know
stuff like that so so do you call god
father absolutely but here's the here's
the point so you comparing God so you
man term here here's the here's the
point no no father is is a god term not
a man's term we are reflecting God's
character it starts with Him Father
Figure starts with God he's the original
father
then want on that right like that's like
a hit or miss like that father ter it's
not a hit or miss it's not a hit or miss
because look this is what I'm talking
about the reason why it's not a hit or
miss is because it was according to the
doctrine of the prophets the Theology of
the prophets what they taught about God
was that he was by identity the heavenly
father he was the heavenly father so
that's by God's identity he he doesn't
change but when we come to the Quran and
Muhammad he he teaches that God
emphatically rejects being a father in
any way shape or form do you know why
doesn't matter why why what you mean it
doesn't matter why the because mean
understand your belief understand your
belie understand like that for me I
question everything so I want to know
why so I question why myself like why
because
anything that in comparison that is
comparing God to any typee of human
relationship or human form or human
anything is we draw a line between that
so God when you say father you can call
another man a father so we don't call go
that's the only reason why because you
don't want to call a Supreme Being
something that you can call all right I
heard you the reason why I disagree is
watch this do you call would can you
call a man your
master you can is Allah your
master yes so that is a title or
relationship that is relatable to Allah
that's shared among
humans but the word I mean we talking
English though no we're not talking
English we're talking we speak master I
mean you say master in English you gon
get that get the same thing but when you
say mo you say mo you talking about a
Mastery that's on a level of ownership
Mastery and S doesn't matter so well
here's the point you have a master and
servant relationship shared between
humans and Allah also takes that or I
wouldn't say he takes that but he also
has that relationship with you that with
Believers that you are that nobody you
know his creation is are his servants
and he is their Master that's literally
what the Quran says so this is a
relatable thing relatable relationship
that we find with Allah that's also
among humans so the excuse that oh well
you know this Father and Son terminology
like that's that's that's stuff that you
that you that's that's human terms
that's human relationships and that God
is way above that well that that that
excuse goes out the window because we
see that Allah uses human terminology
and relationships and applies it to
himself and how he deals with humankind
you know what I'm saying yeah so that
that excuse doesn't work the the very
fact that he goes against the prophet's
theology Man shows that he's not he's
not a prophet of God and what he
experienced was not from God in the
cave okay we we W there in C we in C we
going off beliefs we we both going off
bels at end of day beliefs and beliefs
is not found on knowledge like me and
you know that we talking right now it's
not Bel no belief between that know I'm
saying so know belief are two different
things like we going off something that
been accounted and from the Islam point
of view it has been verified he received
different re in many forms and people
was around anden him witness Revelations
so like I said we based off bels
theories and things that happened in the
past we W there so but we have we have
to we and we have to we have like of
course I wasn't there at Jesus's
crucifixion but I'm believing the report
believe you choose to believe yes I but
I choose I have my I have my reasons why
I'm choosing to believe it I you know so
like when it comes to you know same with
Islam like I am
I don't know for sure if he was in a
cave or not I am only going based off of
the rep the authentic reports about his
life you know that's accepted so I'm
just going off what what you know what
that what that stuff says so according
to what we get we get that he was in a
cave had an experience with some type of
spiritual entity and in that experience
he came out fearful sweating
pulsing you know uh
nervous suicidal Su yep suicidal all of
these things which does not match the
experiences that I see when the prophets
of old have experiences with angels and
with God and you will correct about that
but the
station that Prophet Muhammad
holds is above the station of every
other Prophet no this is what hold on
hold on see you saying no but I'm
telling you to believe
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not here to
tell you this is this and this is that
I'm telling you the belief system itself
the uh what you call it the Creed itself
that's what I'm I'm trying to help you
with that because I know the Creed no I
don't need I don't need like I say we
choose to believe what we want to
believe like if I choose to believe that
a black C cause aad look I choose to
believe that doesn't mean it cause a bad
look you see what I'm saying yes because
I choose to believe it yeah but so
according to the Quran the Quran
literally says this is what Allah says
in the Quran he says we make we make no
distinction between the prophets that's
what Allah says in the Quran we make no
distinction so for you to say that it's
part of the Creed that Muhammad holds a
higher station than the prophets
distinction meaning what distinction
mean what no none of them are greater
than the other there's no difference no
that that that's not the distinction
that it's talking about that's not the
distinction that it's talking about
because it says there are five Prophet a
high Este Jesus Christ the Quran doesn't
say that yes it it say it name of high
okay where give me the verse I had to
find I will find you find right now yeah
yeah we got we got time we chilling man
ain't no rush we chilling like if you
got if you if you got a second device go
ahead and uh Hop On Hop on the search
and I need I want to see that verse
where it says there are five there are
five prophets of high esteem or anything
in that like all right let me see I for
I'm telling you right now man I'm a
shake and I never seen that verse you
what I'm a shake
[Laughter]
Shake all
right I'm going to Old
book because the names I know I know who
they are that's crazy part about it yeah
I mean that that's a it's a I would tell
you that that's more of a tradition that
you've learned not a verse it's not in
the Quran that
there's
I but I know
that by the way on YouTube guys go ahead
and hit the like button um I'm hearing
that the likes are not matching the
viewership we almost got a thousand
people on YouTube watching so go ahead
guys let's hit the like button if you
haven't already if you forgot to do it
make sure you guys smash that like
button like fear Disobedience from it
all right you guys know the drill hit
that like
button while while our friend is looking
for the verse I'm going go ahead and
read a couple of super chats here we got
uh Immortal Immortal who says Genesis 1
127 why out of billions of planets God
decided to give us his image are you
implying that there are aliens that look
like us
too uh it's not about physic ity my
friend it's not about us looking like
God but it's us being made in His image
having his character sharing his traits
in that sense that's in the way that we
are in His image not that we look like
God physically he's not a physical
being he doesn't have a physical
form all
right let's see
here Christianity doesn't have objective
morality it's wrong about Noah's flood
Adam and Eve and the Order of creation
it condones slavery and genocide if you
disagree then add me so we can debate
this come to Tik Tok condone slavery too
uh in the New Testament he had a whole
slave escaped and the man told him go
back to slavery
what Phillip the book is it the book of
Phillip what it the slave escape and is
it's in the it's in the New Testament
bro the whole chapter dedicated to a
slave that escape and they wrote a
letter to tell them go back to slavery
no they said no they they told the
master to free him he was a brother in
Christ well the point of matter is
slavery was still it depends on what
you're talking about I'm Not Who not not
the trans there wasn't no Shadow slavery
in the Bible that wasn't condoned that
was actually condemned it says whoever
SL slavery just ended in recent 1700 18
yeah that type of slavery was not
condoned by the Bible actually according
to the Bible according to the Bible hold
on let me finish bro according to the
Bible that kind of slavery where you
were supposed to be put to death for
that type of slavery if you kidnapped
somebody from their home forced them
into slavery um or sold him off you are
to be put to death and the person who
bought him was to be put to death that's
Exodus chapter
21:16 so yeah uh for that person who's
saying all that kind of stuff you can
come on Tik Tok if you have 200
followers you can come on and uh engage
and you can go ahead and uh bring those
topics up if you
want Shake logic is the truth Jesus
Christ is Lord amen to that God bless
God bless God
[Music]
bless I'm telling you brother it's not
there it don't exist man I would never
lie to you
man don't say all
that
it might been it might been something I
say
but I'm trying to tell you man
sh you might be right shake shake logic
will never lie to you man I'm telling
you shake logic will never lie to you
bro I give you that one but still this
the point of the matter with that bro I
give you that one I can't find I know
Aris so I would say this I would say
this though about that when it said
there no distinction is because people
were making up six making up different
groups foll certain Prophet like some
people follow this Prophet some people
follow this Prophet I'm saying so and
like with Moses and with Jesus some
people remain followers of Moses the
Jews and some people remain followers of
Christ and there was a separation so
that it became a distinction between
which prophet but that the distinction
was eliminated among that said they are
one prop one group it's like one solid
Brotherhood amongst these men yeah but
the five there were five who had high
esteem amongst all of them because you
can't compare
Abraham and Jeremiah you can't compare
mes and Isaiah why not Moses brought a
law why not
though no I'm saying what the people was
doing at the time but I'm saying you're
you're oh you're saying that's what they
were doing yeah okay so so this is the
point that we got to um you have all the
prophets when we read about them and
look at their experiences their
experiences when they experience God and
experience Angels is completely
different from what we see how Muhammad
experienced that spiritual entity that
he found in the cave and that spiritual
entity that he found in the cave we find
no resemblance when it comes to Angels
but we find resemblance when it comes to
Demons we see demon possession that
looks like like that
yeah bro what you keep talk about the
demons for bro you keep cuz he thought
he was demon possessed that's him not me
he Muhammad thought he was demon
possessed and if I was there I would
have put him to the side and said bro
you're you're exactly right I like I
like to think realistic about C things
for me to understand C I was in the same
situation I'm in aave by myself some pop
up out nowhere scared the
hell I might I might CH out too not just
scared not just natural man it's not
just dud it's not just popping out of
nowhere on you it's the the spirit comes
and then grabs him and presses on him to
where he can't breathe and it's like
yelling at him read read he's saying I
can't read lets him go comes back again
grabs him pushes on him presses on him
holds him down until he can't breathe
against his will read read like this
type it's oppression bro you don't see
this with the angels you don't see this
with god with the prophets that's
oppression this is why he was fearful
this is why he was he thought he was
suicide this is why you don't see this
with the prophets bro but you you what
you do see this is if you go to the New
Testament and you look at the demon
possessions that's what you see you'll
see them the bodies being thrown to the
Throne all over the place and them
convulsing and uh being being pressed
and and oppressed that's what you see so
let me ask a question question
sure because you saying this demon
possess stuff right so I'm trying
to what's your question
brother go ahead and ask him
do you
think what all right you know true you
know a tree by the fruit it Bears right
yes so the fruit that came about from
this tree this man cu the tree and the
fruit are symbolic to a man's Deeds so
this tree being Muhammed and the fruit
he brought do you think that could be
some type of demon in in involved any of
this
absolutely hold on hold on hold on so
let's see this religion that this so
This Man call him a man this man
Muhammad BR and over the years what came
about the peace that it brought over the
years hold on when when practice
properly I will say this when practice
properly when practice properly because
because the Crusaders Wars on both sides
and foul play on both sides
throughout the whole and still to this
day it's still some type of Crusades
were to
stop racism and Christianity is probably
no no side is perfect no side is perfect
no side is perfect because did Jesus
teach racism because they preach that in
churches right now no they don't hold on
I seen it before I seen it before they
teach theye they preach against inter
dating they preach against all this type
I've seen before my own eyes there is no
such thing there is no such thing I'm G
tell you this right now bro there is
there is no such thing let me tell you
there is no such thing as a Christian
Church hold onam there is no such thing
as a Christian Church that teaches
racism that teaches Prejudice there's no
such thing anybody that anybody that
claims hear me out anybody that claims
to be a follower of Christ and is
preaching racism is not a Christian it's
as simple as that and that's why and
that's why I want to say to you by any
somebody who CLA to be Muslim or Islam
that does things against peace or
violent it's the same thing no it's not
when it why I say when it practiced
properly I I know and and so that's what
the question is is does Islam teach
these practices or is it against these
practices that's the question and so so
the answer is is that Islam actually
teaches the violence it actually teaches
the uh the Prejudice it actually teaches
these
things BR you got you got tremendous you
got horic War I the
biblee so we not
go like so let's let's let's let's do
this let's look at the fruit because you
because I like that angle because that's
next was is he does he line up with the
prophets no what about his fruits does
his fruits reflect that he's a prophet
of God what taught and how and and what
the people following him practiced let's
see the answer is no so Moses Moses
Moses broke a whole people free from
slavery like he he he did what here did
times 10 yeah but Muhammad didn't
Muhammad owned slaves and sold them
black ones so so you telling me none
other Prophet had slaves are own Ser
Serv they had indentured servitude they
didn't have slaves and and based off
race was
having black
slaves what about having slaves based on
race I mean it was it's an evil I me I
could Don it was a necessary evil it's a
necessary evil that people had to deal I
mean you think it's a NE wait wait wait
wait wait wait wa wait wa wait you think
you think it's a necessary evil to have
slavery based on race because I mean are
we hold on are we going are we going to
call slavery good or me and you going to
call slavering good how how do me you
look at SL as a evil right we look wrong
yeah I'm I'm yeah I'm looking at I'm
look yeah so just understand I'm not
looking at indentured servitude I'm I'm
looking at yeah I'm looking at the SLA
the type of slavery that is cadow
slavery the type of slavery that is
slavery based off race that's the type
of slavery I'm looking at not where
someone volunteers their service and
says hey I I have no way where to go um
I have a family we have no food I will
give you my
services yeah that's inent servitude
that's what the Bible talks about talk
going on yeah and then going okay so
Muhammad Muhammad had slaves based off
their
race what slave he had he had so he had
multiple he had multiple Slavs based off
the race which one so like so I have a
Hadith I was reading to the to the guy
before you it says that Muhammad bought
a non-black slave he was buying a
non-black slave for two black slaves
like he used two black slaves to buy
that one I don't like I don't do the
Hadi Hadi been manipulated and men have
paid a they the Bible how do how do you
know anything about Muhammad
then I don't listen I don't do all the
some that authentic and you is common
sense but a lot of bro well this is
authentic the great manipulated the
greatest sah bro huh the greatest
sah which one the one about him selling
two black slaves for a non-black Slave
I
mean where that at so it's it's hold on
let me turn my screen around so you can
see yourself because say I mean you know
his Kings and rulers who who who force
people to write Hadi and say I mean so I
mean this this is soon this is
sunai sunai
4184 yeah
it says a slave came and pledged to the
prophet to
immigrate allor right to
immigrate and the prophet did not
realize that he was a slave then his
master came looking for him the prophet
said sell him to me and he bought him
for two black
slaves then he did not accept the plagge
from anyone until he asked is he a
slave and the great greatest sah it's
authentic I see bro I don't really too
much man look I a lie
you miss me bro I lie to you bro I
didn't know the history
how kings and rulers and all this stuff
Force Scholars and for people write yeah
so like I mean I'm not saying what
you would you say would would you say
like that that right there what we just
read is is wrong would you say that I
wouldn't say that I mean I would have to
actually look at it as sit there and
stud
like like that don't sound right that
sound like something goes
against like most people do like you
find one that contradicts something else
like you disagree with
the
go to trade one two kind and two black
slay
specifically I mean I mean I understand
you saying about the color but I'm
saying just the thing for one for two it
don't even sound right sound like that's
that's that's what it was bro
one most one for two
he was against well he's not he's not
against slavery bro so look look look at
the chapter heading I'm not saying
against SL I'm I'm not saying against
slavery I'm saying against sing one of
for two of the same well he wasn't bro
look look look at the um look look at
the chapter heading bro this is what
also gets me about this the chapter
heading selling animals for Animals
[Music]
bro I mean it's always been
racism but this is Islam it's not just
Arabs Salam this is Islam that we're
talking about forget forget Arab culture
or
anybody and I would say this withoud I
would say this Unapologetic Arabs are
not like I didn't heard Arabs say that
black people can't be
Muslim I heard is like just like two
weeks ago you know what I'm saying yeah
so it's like I understand like they
mindset so I understand like that racism
I understand that but do you see like
remember do it has it right it's true so
here here's my thing though CU remember
we're talking about fruits so the Arabs
who follow Muhammad would have a basis
for acting the way they're acting
because of stuff like this because stuff
like this is in Islam where selling
animals for Animals selling black slaves
buying them and for for one non black
like they're they're worth less or
whatever like that that type of ideology
is in Islam so they have a basis for
having that attitude is it is it Islam
or is it in culture it's in is that this
is Islam bro if
for the mus for the Muslim Arabs for the
Muslim Arabs who have a racist undertone
to their
attitude they get it from Islam it's
embedded in
Islam I want to say they get it from
Islam because I don't want to say that I
don't want to say they get it from Islam
I don't want to use that particular word
I want to because that particular word
has its own meaning So when you say
Islam you say submission of God that's
how I translate that in my mind oh on
because linguistically that's what it
comes out to that's how I translate well
when we're talking about no when we're
talking about Islam we're talking about
the religion that Muhammad came
professing and teaching in in in the
Arabian Peninsula how you want it for
this
conversation yeah that's what this is of
it yeah that's what this is so what
we're talking about is the fruits we're
talking about the fruits that come from
Muhammad we already saw that his
experience was not like the
prophets and now we're seeing what are
his fruits what is he teaching what is
he doing this is an example selling
animals for Animals two black slaves for
non one non-black and there's multiple
there's more stuff like this
bro there's more stuff like
this this is this is what I I can't I
can't I can't I can't like I say you out
deep I can't go like you understand what
if we go to the Quran you focus on we
focus on something that that me myself
if I would have seen it I would have
said something something would have
stuck out to me too yeah I would have
seen the hiden animal animal seen like
but I already know about the history of
the ARs the history of the AR slave
trade just had just say you had the
European slave trade it both Europeans
and and Arab was doing the same thing
with two different religions to the same
the same
thing you see what I'm saying so it's
not the religious and
now it was the people themselves okay
so
Rel okay so if that's the case then why
is Muhammad doing this if it's not part
of the religion why is Muhammad doing
and acting like this I don't think he
did that I ain't G lie bro that don't I
mean no see it doesn't fit what you
you're that's my first time you pul that
out that's my first time even seeing
something of that
nature yeah because look what I'm on the
interneto that's on interet anybody it's
the Hadith that's the HS are on the
internet asa.com that's in the books
that's in the books
[Music]
bro get a old book get a old ma book get
a old joh
book get in the
books but I'mma show you I'mma show you
more things in
this I se you other day and whole thing
be talking about Jesus God you still a
told me what Jesus said I did tell you
you just rejected it I did tell you just
re did say show you those places too but
right now we're in a right now right now
we're at we're at a good place right
now you know I'm saying I
won't right now right now we're at a
good place man you know we're at a good
place I want to show you I want to show
you in the Quran it's racist too the
same
stuff I show you the same thing in the
Quran yeah this is this is the fruits of
Islam bro this is the fruits of
Muhammad SL say slave trading
Man black people people that look like
you and
me I mean but they been
white white uh I guess had come
yes we would absolutely absolutely what
do you
mean come on
man go well no well well I'm I'm
touching on it because we're talking
about the racism in Islam and what it
touches on the evil things it's fruit
what about the racism Christianity there
is no racism in Christianity there's not
a there look notice how you see how I
can pull up a reference within Islamic
sources showing racism you can't do that
with the Bible you can't go to a single
verse in the Bible and pull out uh pull
out racism you can't because it doesn't
exist I mean you can with the Jews and
the Gentile because because the Jew
didn't want see the Gentiles because why
they wasan it was a form of
racis Jesus said I came from no no stop
stop stop Salam Salam stop stop right
there so what you Salam stop right there
what you have in the Bible with it comes
to the Jews and the Gentiles the Bible
says in Christ there is neither Jew nor
Gentile no Jew nor Gentile no free nor
slave so the Jew Who's acting weird
towards a gentile and in in fact Peter
was doing this and was called out by it
by Paul was
corrected that type of stuff is
corrected in the Bible you'll never see
that stuff condoned or or or you know
allowed you'll never see that you'll see
it
checked right on the spot Peter got
checked for acting different toward the
Gentiles
you're right about that yeah in Islam I
can show you this stuff of clear racism
unchecked promoted allow in the in the
Quran or outside both I just showed you
outside the Quran I can show you in in
the
Quran all right all right let's go go to
chapter 3 verse
106 chapter 3 verse 106
bro we not going to do that
bro bro that's not talking about no
slavery or nothing like that bro that's
not bro you know what Elijah har used
the same thing to turn the corona
against white people bro he use the same
type of play on words to say that the
white people will show the blue eye
white devil because of certain ver of
thean because certain color whatever but
they saying
black is just a color that people have
always associated with
evil and white is always been a term
that people always associated with white
that's why I don't let people call me
black I really don't like people call me
black because I'm not I don't like that
term you see what I'm saying but like
I'm saying like that that verse right
there bro has nothing to do with slavery
or anything like that so let's read it
it says on the day on the day of
Resurrection some fa when some faces
will become White
and some faces will be will become black
yeah as for those whose faces will
become
white I'm sorry uh uh as for those faces
who as for those whose faces will become
black it will be said to them did you
reject Faith after accepting it then
taste the torment for rejecting Faith
that's what happens when you know you're
going to turn
black and as for those fa that will
become white they will be in Allah's
Mercy therein they shall dwell
forever and and if not you you gonna be
turned
black I see what you saying what you get
but I don't get that read
that I don't see that because it'sing
about a whole different sense like you
have to actually go deep to the a itself
and pull out as me like
I don't the English translation is weak
okay so let me show you now the
background of
this I want to show you man that we
don't we don't make this stuff up man so
even in the Quran it says that people's
faces will be turned white and they're
going to heaven and then people will be
turned black and they're going to
hell wow but hey you know that's um you
know you got to you got to dive deep
into the Arabic I guess to really uh I
mean I mean I mean would you associate
black I
have yeah the word is black it's black
and white is associated with
what in the in the English dictionary
what you get black you see evil you see
dark I mean the same thing you call
yourself black not in the Bible you call
yourself the same thing not in the Bible
I'm just saying like so why you stand
with I mean
like let me show you let me show let me
show you something I know you said you
don't like Hadith but I have to show you
this come on I have to show you this
just because because we're on that you
know that that part that subject there
so I have to show you this
okay
this is tough
man there's there's no way uh you
know that I could I could be Muslim with
this stuff there's no way in the world I
mean I couldn't be Christian at I heard
this the History part from our ancestors
I could do that know but really the same
thing on both sides do you do you
understand do you understand the
difference between CU you I think that
you actually started off explaining this
the difference between what the religion
actually teaches but and what bad people
do so both sides yeah so bad people
doing things in Christianity that goes
against the Bible they're not Christians
even if they claim they are they're not
Christians and woe to them you can't
find what they do taught in the Bible
that's my point like Oklahoma City oklah
back name ofr yeah none of none of that
is in none of that is in the Bible the
Bible is emphatically against that but
in Islam I'm showing you that this stuff
is in Islam it's in the teachings of
Islam it's not that there's bad Muslims
who are going against the religion you
know and no they are in this is what is
taught in Islam that's what I'm showing
you it's a huge difference slavery SL so
would you have if if you could have a
slave would you have a slave right now
if I can have a maid to clean my house
absolutely
fu yeah but I'm not yeah I would never
have I would never have a slave like you
have a servant I would never I would
yeah I would have a servant I would
never have a I would never have a slave
where I bought them you know uh based
off their race they're stolen from their
home uh and I I would never indulge in
that I would always condemn that
always you know so all right look so
look at this oh great it is man it is
man but but you know you know this why
this why you know I I do this man you
know say Jesus is
G you still got I already showed you all
that you switched the go post on
me at first you asked me where in the
Bible does it say Jesus is God so I
showed you but then you was like oh well
no Revelation ain't good enough I want
to see Matthew Mark Luke and John
now why he why ler
say later say that well that's not 300
years later my friend it's not 300 years
I I hope you don't have you do you think
that God can't reveal things in a
vision does it does it does it matter if
he says it in the vision
or he said wait wait if he if whether he
says I'm the first and the last here in
the flesh on Earth or if he says it when
he's in heaven and gives that a
revelation to John what what's what's
the
difference
I did back it
up Revelation chap 22:
13 all right so watch this man I I don't
want us to get off track of this let's
down so this is mishkat Al masabi masabi
119 it's also transmed in Jamia
terminally and stuff like that so this
is what it says bro
says Abu da reported God's messenger is
saying God created
Adam when he create and God created Adam
when he created him and struck his right
shoulder and brought forth his offspring
white like small
ants and he struck his left shoulder and
brought forth his offspring black as
though they were
charcoal then he said to the party on
his right side to the white Offspring to
paradise and I do not
care and he said to the party in his
left shoulder the black ones to hell and
I do not
care similar to what we just saw in the
Quran this this is talking about just
straight up Offspring cre it this way
they created White created black whites
go to heaven black people go to hell
this is this is literally
race I'm not I'm not I mean I'm not
going to go against what you saying
right there but like I said at the same
time like when it comes first of all the
Hadi is got one name at the beginning of
it like how these like they got one name
the beginning of it I don't read period
I got to see a change from that got it
from
Usain liard deep anyway and I had that
right to you know what I'm saying like
I'm like man this sound like some racist
[__] excuse my langu this sound like
some RAC [__] that put in sometime I
know look at it and dis that but that's
not what they done that through history
that's not what it is bro this isn't
know that what you mean that's not
that's what I'm take it like I'm saying
because they done that through our
history this is Islam bro this is Islam
this is Islam it's not it's not racist
Arabs who's trying to and maybe it is
but this is Islam at the end of the day
I say this it's you can say Islam
because it's in the books or whatever
and it's being promoted it's being
taught because it's in books or people
are being taught this stuff but is it
pure and authentic Islam in its true
Essence no it's not not Islam cuz I'm
say that's not Islam man what the I'm
look at you somebody tell don't sound
right don't even sound right don't go
against it don't sound right first of
all it's a story about something that
happened at the beginning of time
supposedly that nobody was there you see
what I'm saying so it sound like some
fairy tale story anyway that somebody
said Muhammad said you see what I'm
saying what I'm saying like that don't
even sound right well this is what like
the same conversation look the same
conversation I'm telling
you I tell musl the same thing I'm not I
standing for a whole of but this is what
it is bro this is what I'm saying like I
can show you like all I can show you the
Quran I can show you these Hadith what
I'm showing you is that this is in the
Islamic sources this is what is taught
in the Islamic sources you know what I'm
saying so if
people it does make it Islamic because I
can put out things in chrisan
it depend do domination want go no if
you pull if you pull out something in
the Bible if you pull out something in
the Bible That's Christianity I'm
talking abouts you just put something
outside the Quan
that's being taught in
Christianity no this dude oh my goodness
the Hadith let me ask do you believe
that Hadith and and how many times a day
do you
pray you get that from the Hadith you
know that right no you get that from
Quan it's in the CH it tell you time it
said the rising the Sun the setting of
The Sun it say it give you five
times show me where it mentions five
prayers it don't say five it says yeah
yeah just like where it shows yeah show
me where it where it shows the five
prayers you know there's only so much I
can do man I all I can do is just show
you the stuff and then you know you do
what you you do what you want after you
can either duck your head under the sand
and ignore it and say this ain't the
Islam that I know and love uh so I may
just ignore this stuff or you can see
what Islam actually teaches reject it
and come out of that
Darkness but all I can do is just show
you
man
you got to come out of this
man 11 it's multiple vers
11 114 said establish prayer at the two
ends of the day and in the first hour of
the
night how many so the begin they just
praying two three times a day pray
establish off the so two ends of the day
and at the what last hour of the night
first hour of the night first hour first
hour of the
night says 30 verse 17 to 18 says
glorify Allah in the evening and in the
morning that's what we just heard no
different
that refers to the morning prayer and it
refers to the afternoon prayer no it
doesn't it says the morning and the
afternoon that's what we just
heard I'm sorry yeah it says the morning
the evening which is the first hour of
the night and at the end of the night
that's the that's the other prayer that
we heard that's still just that's still
just
three
no it's the prayers at the two ends of
the day the two ends of the day are
forer the morning prayer the first
prayer and the third prayer the four the
fourth of M and the first uh one of the
night
issue forer Sunset the dawn prayer the
sunset prayer and the night prayer
Sunset prayer the sunset prayer is the
first hour of the night that's the
evening a
sunset that's not the first hour like
the first hour of night when night when
the sun actually disappear and the
redness of the sky disappear disappears
also that's the first hour of the
night that's sunset sunset and night
time two different it's still bright at
Sunset right
around that's the first hour of the
night
bro it says be PR and glorify him again
in night and also it say hold on it say
before the sun rise and before the sun
set before the sunrise and before the
sunet so before the sunet is what you
know I I another prayer another prayer
right I I honestly so that's we add the
PO prayer we no you didn't it's
repeating itself in many different ways
no it's not okay I it's it's
okay my brother it's okay it's okay it's
okay I'll let you have it because I this
literally it like it doesn't it it
doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter to me like when it comes to our
our conversation like I not want to
spend time on this because you know to
you be yours on that you're the one who
brought it up you're the one who brought
I know and and I see I see that we're
going to keep going through the Quran
looking at these verses that talk about
the three prayers and how it repeats
itself and you're G to you're going to
interpret it how you still want to it's
still not five but I'm G let you bro I'm
G let you you got it you got that I want
to stay focused on the issue here okay
the issue here is what the Quran is
teaching what the Hadith are teaching
and the fruits that we see coming from
Muhammad what we see one of the aspects
of that that we're seeing is
racism that's what that's what we're
landing
on the black and white stuff black
people going to hell white folks going
to heaven being turned white being
turned black selling two black slaves
for one non-black slave we see the
racism embedded in Islam from Muhammad's
teachings and
actions you get what I'm
saying
what understand come
from come from okay but does it make it
right me I don't
think and like I said and I say this
again I don't think that is pure pure
Islam teaching in his Essence because
the teaching Islam has always been
taught before my
the P essence of
it okay so that I'm not I'm not going to
say that I'm repeat this again that's
not Islamic teaching that's notl okay so
then if you're saying if you're saying
that the pure Islam was it was even here
before Muhammad and it was the pure
submission of God without racism with
love and equality and things of this
nature that was the pure Islam then
Muhammad came and taught and practiced
an impure Islam is that fair to
say no I won't say that either so the
slavery that you're seeing from Muhammad
the teachings on black and white that
you're seeing from Muhammad you're
saying you agree that that's pure Islam
then I don't I don't think that's P
that's not P I don't think
talk I think
that people who had influence people who
had
power manipulated and did they thing had
their way with certain ticks certain
books and certain doctrines and
influence that put that in there for
their
own reason whatever that's why I think
that's my Bel Ian because it don't make
sense that's not PR Islam
teacher what I'm saying yeah and for
some for somebody to hold for for a
person Muslim not think that that it
those birth that you just show are true
and authentic like a fool too I'mma ask
you one more thing
um how how do you feel about uh men
grown men sleeping with little
girls little girls like you talking
about man
look I don't
think and I Haven I read different
sources different age groups I know what
you foret at with his young wife and
stuff like that I don't know I seen one
said that she was nine I seen one that
say she was 13
there's not a single Hadith that say she
was
13 not a single
[Music]
one I just seen what people basically
would guesstimate her age got it so yeah
just to be clear every Hadi every Hadith
is the same she was six or seven when he
married her um but it's consistent that
she was nine when he consummated the
marriage with her but that's not what I
really was asking you but going on with
that what do you think about that about
Muhammad sleeping with Aisha at at her
age what do you think about
that I mean standard that's wrong but
then back then that was perfectly normal
for anybody of any any cultureal race in
in Africa that was
normal in in in Uganda that was noal
does it does it
does does it make it right does it make
it right if it's
normal it don't okay so so I was stand I
was standing against hold on I'm
standing against it I'm on the same like
I say that wrong
I'm saying
those
everybody culture I disagree but even if
that was the case yeah that's not
true hold on hold on hold on hold on
because that's not even the issue right
now I'm let's say that that's true that
doesn't make it right correct yeah
you're right right so so then Muhammad
is still doing something wrong even if
it's normal right I mean we call it it
wrong now they didn't call it wrong then
oh who cares if it if who called it
wrong it's either wrong or it's not I
mean I'm pretty sure everybody I mean a
lot of people didn't nobody speak up
against it back then nobody it wasn't
looked down upon back then see what I'm
saying see now okay like it's like hold
on like this nowadays like it's either
it's wrong or it's not bro it's
homosexuality wrong huh it's
homosexuality wrong yeah well we can't
talk about that here because T about
about about this okay forication is
wrong what is fornication wrong yes okay
and fornication was wrong all way up to
the 1930s in American history it was
used to be only it used to be a criminal
punishment for fornication and adultery
in America on these lands all the way up
to the 1930s okay because it was deemed
Wrong by most people but now me and you
still look at it wrong but everybody
else I don't care about everybody else's
eyes is it still wrong or not
this I'm saying bro we right here with
this he like right here BR I'm not I
need you to understand Salam I'm not
asking about opinion I'm asking about a
a truth is right or wrong is it right is
it wrong is I'm saying it's wrong I'm
saying it's wrong I said okay even if
even if more people say no it's okay
it's still wrong right in our eyes yeah
no no no I'm not asking about in our
eyes I'm not asking here it is again if
if Salam I'm not asking about our
opinion I'm not asking about our
favorite flavor of ice cream in our eyes
in your eyes stra strawberry is good in
my eyes it's chocolate relative that's
not yeah I'm not asking about Rel is is
morality relative or is it
objective it depend where you live it
depend how you brought up on your
environment so you're saying that
morality is is relative is there ever is
there ever a time where grape sleeping
with
someone uh against their will is there
ever a time in any culture where that is
okay no that's not I mean you I agree
with you 100% well so so even if if it
was lawful in a
culture I'm back I'm back even if it
even if it was if it was lawful
pertaining to a particular culture and
time and they was like yeah it's it's
okay it's it's perfectly lawful they
would that entire culture would be wrong
correct say you deal you talking about
America right now I'm saying like so
they would be wrong correct I mean I
mean in our eyes yeah no would they be
wrong yes or no whether let's say in my
eyes it was okay would they be wrong yes
or no you you wrong okay so regardless
of if it's in my eyes regardless of the
time frame regardless of the culture
grape forcing yourself sexually on
another human being is wrong period
doesn't matter the culture doesn't
matter the religion doesn't matter of
the time it's objectively wrong
regardless of our opinion yeah you're
right good so morality is objective it's
not based on how you feel or I feel
issue situ you talking about rape though
you talking about rape though mean of
course anybody going to say that wrong
because you force somebody against their
will you take away their free will it's
not ensal okay so now I'm asking you
this now so now I'm asking you this for
a grown man listen Salam let's translate
now this issue for a grown
man to have sexual relations with a
child is that ever
okay not to me no so then Muhammad was
wrong when he did it
correct I mean if that was the
case was was he wrong with it did and
why did nobody else speak up on it
that's just an argument of Silence we
don't know if people did it just answer
the question because I told you I gave
you my answer I gave answer so Muhammed
was
wrong is does that make it okay why we
why are we backtracking does that make
it
okay if you live if you lived in that
time if you lived in that time and it
was normal in your culture does that
make it okay for a grown man to sleep
with a kid it wasal it was normal in
Jesus time to kill kids who disrespect
can you answer the question no that's
not about kids that's about that's about
uh young adults who understand the law
who know right from wrong it's not about
kids so now but still please stop trying
to change it stop trying to change it
Salam Salam now you're now you're
running from the issue
now I said yesong I wrong so then
Muhammad was wrong when he did it
correct so wait so Muhammad was wrong
when he did it correct
bro we I said I said yes is wrong and I
said yes I mean what you I just need to
hear so when you say yes I'm I'm trying
to be clear because I don't want to
misrepresent you Muhammad was wrong when
he slept with the child Aisha correct if
that happen if that happen if that
happen if it did happen yes well that
that's what the that's what you know
that's what the text says that's so it
did happen I mean I se I just seen
multiple it's the debate about the age
there's no debate about
the okay let's see let's
see iar you I hear you I hear you I hear
you read a book we there I hear you
let's let's see if there was a debate
about the age you're right let's see if
there was a debate about the age let's
see let's see if we find one source that
says she wasn't nine when he slept with
her let's just
see okay here's the First Source sah
bukari here's the first
Source narrated oh shoot this is
narrated by Aisha
herself you do you think that she knew
her own age or
no bro got over 5,000 you think that
woman had 5000 for real do you think
that she knew her own age come on let's
go let's go let's go okay so Aisha
she's the prophet married her when she
was six years old and he consummated his
marriage when she was 9 years old that's
one
SD person do do you want it in first
person I can get it for you in first
person saying that's second person
here's another one saykar 5158 the
prophet narrated Aura the prophet wrote
the uh the marriage contract with Aisha
while she was six years old and
consummated the his marriage with her
when she was nine and she remained with
him for nine years who this
of person all right here it goes
again sah bukari is another one we BR
what do you mean weak this is
sah
I'm we like we
like notice notice how each all right
here's Aisha here you wanted first
person here's Aisha narrated Aisha the
messenger of
married me when I was 7 years
old the narrator suon said or six years
he had intercourse with me when I was n
years old I'm lie y coms
nobody a whole different right yeah just
yeah just F just focus on me forget the
comment section you see how Aisha is
speaking in in first person now okay so
she says that he consummated the
marriage he had he had intercourse
excuse me she says he had
intercourse with me when I was n years
old wow wow was she
bleeding was
beding that's everybody
think do you think this is okay bro I
don't think it's okay I'm not do anybody
back I
mean bro you talking about, 1400 years
ago people was doing that all the way up
to the
17 1800 bro look at all these all of
these sources are saying the exact same
there's no difference all of them are
saying she was nine years old when he
had sex with her bro every single one is
saying the same thing watch this oh this
one is good sahim Muslim this is
authentic 1422 C it says Aisha Allah be
pleased with her reported that Allah's
Apostle married her when she was seven
years old and he was taken to and he was
taken to his house oh she was taken to
his house as a bride when she was 9
years old when he slept with her and her
dolls were with
her and when he died she was 18 years
old you think she was an adult playing
with dolls at
nine bro she was playing with dolls bro
I'm saying adult I'm saying adult
meaning like when a person reach pu
puberty bro when a person reach pu they
able to have kids they can sit up that
that doesn't make a person an adult
man yeah if she if she bleed she breed
huh if she bleed she
breed no it
wasn'ta you stud history
I who cares about what other people were
doing we're talking about a
prophet good so the prophet was
wrong so guess I got you I got
you now now let me ask you this bro let
let me ask you this let me ask you this
because you know that this is still
going on in certain countries right
certain Islamic countries yeah that [__]
going on right across the border in
Mexico what you talking about [__] so
right so so for these people Salam for
these people the Muslims who do this
they have a basis for doing it right
because their Prophet did it so they're
as so as Muslims they're saying well
this is this is okay in Islam it's okay
to do this our Prophet did it he's the
best example our Prophet did it so this
is okay so you drink wine so you drink
alcohol you drink yeah I drink alcohol
okay yeah why because turn water wi
Jesus turned water to wine Jesus drank
it's all of that all right okay so now
so don't let's not run away from the
issue okay okay so in Islam it is okay
to sleep with young
girls this is taught in Islam because
your Prophet these are the fruits of
your Prophet bro all right you know what
I'm G ask somebody about that I'm I'm do
me a survey of people who who sleep NY
I'm go ask a whole bunch of this weekend
they sleep n I'm G get their answers I'm
come back with you see what I'm saying
that's that's an interesting topic
though that's interesting topic I'm G
ask some people like I'm ask some people
out the about that
now sure now do you want to see that the
Quran actually teaches and says this is
okay too yeah come on please please
please please I got you remember you
said well you know they were doing it um
they were doing it before they before
like when when they hit puberty you know
that's you know they they were seen as
adults right I mean I'm going to show
you that the Quran taught that it was
okay even before they hit
puberty that's what I'm going to show
you that's what I'm going to show you
bro and if you stay in the religion
after this I don't know what to tell you
man if you if you still rocking with
Muhammad after this
[Laughter]
man okay okay okay let me just see if I
can zoom in on this real
quick let me see if I can zoom in hold
on man if you stay after this man
there's a problem man I don't know what
to tell you man there's a
problem all right hold on let me
uh that's not how I want
it okay this is the best we I'mma get
I'mma hold it close so you can see it I
see see oh you see it okay for for sure
for sure all
right so this is talking about divorce
this is chapter
65:4 literally the chapter is called you
know it's called talak which means
divorce in Arabic okay so this is what
it says here in verse
four it's teaching you how to divorce
three categories of females okay it says
and those of your women as have passed
the age of monthly
courses for them the ID the prescribed
period if you have doubt is three months
now let me slow down when it says the ID
the prescribed period That's a waiting
period that a woman has to wait um
before she can move on to the next man
okay it's to make sure she's not
pregnant you know what I'm saying so
that's why they're checking like you
know for a woman who's passed her
ministration like menopause she's P the
age of monthly courses so she doesn't
get periods and you you know you slept
with her she was your wife you're
divorcing her but and you're unsure if
she might be pregnant she ain't she's
not getting periods to let you know then
her waiting period is three months to
make sure she's not pregnant okay make
sense yeah all right all right so let's
move on so yeah so her waiting period is
three months and for those who have no
courses their periods now the
commentator here says I.E they are still
immature so that their understanding is
their divorcing you know it says they
have no courses these are obviously they
haven't had periods yet that's what it
says for those who have not had who have
no courses they haven't had periods yet
they're divorcing girls who haven't had
their periods their ID their waiting
period before they can move on to the
next man is also three months like the
woman in
menopause okay
now and it says here and for those who
are
pregnant their
ID is until they lay down their burden
right that's obviously until they give
birth and whoever fears Allah and keeps
his duty to him he will make his matter
easy for him now I don't have no problem
with the Third Woman the pregnant woman
I have no problem with the older one my
problem is category number
two the
females they're divorcing who have not
had their
periods the ones who are
immature I see what you're
saying now it gets
worse because I want you to realize this
because we're not just talking about
marriage contracts oh they married them
but they didn't maybe they didn't
consumate the marriage
no the fact that they have a waiting
period right remember the waiting period
is to make sure she's not pregnant so
the fact that the little girl who's
being divorced has a waiting period
means that her husband slept with
her that's why she has a waiting
period because they're trying to make
sure she's not
pregnant let me show you that the Quran
actually says this the Quran literally
actually has a verse that says this that
there is if there is no uh if you
haven't touched her she has no ID there
is no h no hit know I know what you're
talking about y so you already know but
let let me just just for those who maybe
you know thinking I'm lying or something
like that for
them am I
tripping oh it's 49 my
bad there we go
so this is chapter 33: 49 of the Quran
guys chapter 33: 49 of the
Quran it says oh you who
believe when you marry oh let me fix
this when you marry believing women and
then divorce them before you have sexual
intercourse with them no
ID have you to count for them now look
it even like you know the the the
commentator even puts in the verse we
just came from
654 like it puts that in these two
verses go
together so there is no ID there is no
waiting period if you ain't h no h no
it so the reason why those little girls
who have not had their periods who have
not reached puberty have an Ida is
because their husband's
hi they
smashed this
is not
disagree
yeah so
bro what what we saying I give you that
now if it's saying what it's
saying I
give so if you
still let's get back on
let's get back on top I this anyway no
this is the topic this this is the
topic no no no no no bro
list you ain't about to it's Jesus God
your way out of this one
man he trying to is Jesus God your way
out of
[Laughter]
it Salam bro you are funny man
that's you me that you me that I
[Music]
that L
188 go for you that's fine all but look
before we go to the Bible and I want to
because I want to be fair I want you to
bring up your objections to the Bible
and deal with it because you're you're
dealing with Islam I I want to deal with
the Bible so we'll do that but first I
gotta hear you
man what's up bro I gotta hear you man
what's up you know I say
that so with with this being and what
you consider the word of God and you
know that this is wrong you know that
this can't be from God
right I
mean I'm G say this in all confidence
bro with the Bible and the Quran bro
through our history bro I know that man
had played a part in the OR in how can I
say
this twisting up and messing with the
originality of both texts bro so I don't
know I'm not saying look I'm look that
right there was kind of like man hold on
know I'm saying so I don't know like
I I don't want you to just take it out
the on the
[Laughter]
chin look that I I don't just want you
to take it on the chin man like this is
you know if you watch me bro I don't I
don't do this for got you points I I
don't care about that I care about truth
and understanding I don't I don't want
you to just be like yeah you know what
you got me on this I want you to have
the conviction and understanding that
this cannot possibly be the word of God
it
can't okay not teaching this
stuff remember we was talking about the
fruits what would what do we go over the
consistency Muhammad is not in line with
how God Reveals His message with how the
angels in God reveal come experien
Prophets You Know come to the prophets
different from how
muhamad right now I gota go I gota go
for real you
better
man
was a
good
L bro same time bro I'm I stand for
right now do my
[Laughter]
little bro leave this religion get out
of there man hey I'm G be back
[Music]
all right peace all right peace
peace what y'all what Y what what what
y'all think about that
man y'all tell me what what y'all think
about about
this what y'all think
man woo
what y'all think about
this you know I I I I just I just
pray even if I don't talk to him
again I pray that the Holy Spirit Pricks
at his heart man and I mean I mean hug
on it I mean I pray that the Holy Spirit
you
know doesn't allow him to sleep
comfortably and can convicts
him convicts
him of the truth of Christ and the
falsehood of of of
Islam
that's that's my prayer man it got out
of here you know said he had a call he
said he had a call he got out of
here before we
can drive and twist that nail just in
case you listening Salam I want we gonna
drive that nail in man
we're gonna drive that nail in